this week on wealth in Russia fleeing to
India we hinder seek shelter we begin on
the island of Prince IPE of the coast of
West Africa struggling against waves of
plastic waste the island has set an
ambitious goal
it wants to be plastic free by 2020 is a
way of life on Prince EA but they're
definitely not taking the easy road when
it comes to protecting the environment
24 year-old selena Fernandez has a big
day ahead good morning I've come for
your plastic bottles today's collection
day you got them all ready recycling
plastic has become a major activity on
the island and young and old are getting
in on the action the collection depot
will be busy the entire day the routine
is get in line and be patient
Selene Fernandez is helping out with the
counting she works in the biosphere
reserve team she says most of the
plastic bottles arriving on the island
contain palm oil for cooking by holding
collections every few months the team
has gathered up four hundred and fifty
thousand bottles for every 50 they hand
out a reusable container made of
stainless steel prima deliver the
plastics we have four tons of plastic
stored on the main island of South amaze
a maritime transport company is helping
us by taking it to Lisbon free of charge
to recycling companies there will
receive it mass tourism hasn't yet come
to the island and that's the way they
want to keep it but the locals also need
jobs so the idea is to upcycle the
islands waste 70% of which is organic
these women are making commercial
compost it's a new venture on the island
and it's hard work the compost beds need
to be turned three times a week that's
bad the women are aiming to sell their
first compost in three months
they've already approached potential
clients and they hope all their hard
work will eventually pay off this means
a lot to us we've never had jobs before
this is about our children's future and
we're determined to build something here
for the next generation if boy Felipe is
named principal Ireland certainly not
taking the easy way
[Music]
for some they considered monsters even
by their own parents homosexuals in
Russia Natalya and her mother spoke to
us about their struggle in st.
Petersburg
[Music]
they were running around school
screaming that I'm a damn lesbian and
that I should die their homophobia was
reason enough to attack me
[Music]
[Music]
yeah but if lost honestly when I started
dancing I met people I knew I'd feel
comfortable with most of them are either
bisexual or lesbian it gives me a
feeling of freedom my mother was really
upset when she found out she cried a lot
it was a shock for us she I'll admit I
even felt physical was just a version oh
my god is my daughter a monster or a
freak - those shoe once I certainly felt
uneasy about it you pretty open it with
why she got into you and what will
people say there are people who can
never find out you can't even hint at it
that it doesn't I can see that she wants
to understand me but she can my parents
were brought up in the Soviet Union with
Tristan what is this year we went on a
trip to Greece and went to an island
where there was a monastery and pilgrims
one woman went down on her knees and
crawled to the monastery I was surprised
maybe if she wanted God to help her heal
someone Luther and then I thought to
myself if someone told me to get down on
my knees and crawl and then my daughter
would be just like everyone else I would
do it a book bottle
unless another day in Russia the
reaction is harsh
some parents freak out and kick their
kids out of the house even disown them
and that's not all
one girl I know her father almost killed
her for it he beat her up
just initial USB watch them quickly
remember what you couldn't when I was 14
my classmates and some of the kids at
school found out they spat at me hit me
with their heavy backpacks filled with
books beat me up and insulted me I
freaked out I cried because I was so
scared my life was over the most amiable
oh watch instructional yep English for
she's using me of opportunity Buddhist
[Music]
homosexual relationships are seen as
degrading here people react really
aggressively to them if I realize at
some point that I just can't live here
anymore I'll have to find a way to leave
[Music]
[Applause]
many rehén jure muslims forced to flee
Myanmar have found refuge in India but
New Delhi may want to send them back
happy thought mad tells us about his
fear
[Music]
they live in squalor but at least this
safe
a group of RO hinge refugees have made
this shantytown in Delhi the home many
work as rag pickers and casual laborers
this is where we met Hafiz Ahmad last
year he had arrived two years ago he had
been issued refugee documentation by the
United Nations but he was struggling to
feed his five children he couldn't find
work he didn't speak Hindi and found it
hard to adapt to India but a year on
things have changed Hafiz can navigate
Delhi's chaotic roads
ever since he began driving a rented
rickshaw it brings him a regular income
between five to six euros a day his
children study in a government school
today he picks up his daughter Moony
ethnic javi says he's grateful to India
for the chance to build a new life for
himself and his family
he's even picked up Hindi allowing him
to connect more deeply with the country
that's given him refuge I meet a lot of
Indian commuters through my work I
interact more with Indians now than with
people from my own community that has
definitely helped my Hindi it's
improving and I wanted to become even
better in future like these many here
have integrated into Indian society
hafiz can't read and write
but he keeps up with the news on dozens
of whatsapp groups where users post
graphic videos of the unfolding crisis
on the Myanmar border Hafiz is no doubt
what a deputation in these circumstances
will mean if the Indian government
forcibly sends us back my children's
future will be ruined everything will be
over
there's no humanity Myanmar towards Roo
hinges we'll all be killed if we're sent
back the feelings are shared by many of
her pieces friends in the settlement
there's little else they speak of
nowadays I'm very scared
my mother ancestors still live in
Myanmar some of my relatives have been
killed where would we go but some are
clinging on to a sliver of hope when I
fled from Myanmar and came to India I
realized everyone has rights here even
animals have rights
this is a law-based country there's
equality I can't imagine the government
will send us back during this crisis
it's something this true hinge a
community desperately wants to believe
in
Kanon traditional bookstores survived in
the age of the Internet
mas Rogers ohm says they must he
operates one of France's oldest book
shops in the middle of Paris the
Francois shoe psalm can't imagine a life
without books this small bookstore in
the center of Paris has been run by his
family for four generations
cyclamen under this is a very
sentimental place for me it's tied to
many memories and it exudes a certain
kind of life being a bookseller means
humbly passing something on that's
existed for generations we can't ever
let this history of ideas be interrupted
the oldest bookstore in Paris was also
an online pioneer Husum has been
shipping books customers purchased on
the internet for 20 years now still
sales are falling he now hopes a new
initiative will help around 700
booksellers in the country have set up a
database that lets customers reserve and
pick up books at leisure decor packed
here it's all about proximity when many
people come to pick up a book they often
forget at first that they ordered it
online
this initiative allows us to once again
establish human contact with customers
Francois jerusem remains optimistic that
small stores like his will survive
there's no fifth generation Jew soon to
take over the family business but the
bookseller hopes to one day find a
successor to help keep the spirit of his
historic store alive
[Music]